and welcome to the first half of top 32
myself Romanova in the building
Tenkaichi event for first attack and do
we got a banger to start it off for one
oh yeah we have Lord Wawa versus Lord
Nakia indeed Wawa who I mean I think
it's top 3 in this game currently bar
none easy
yeah not Nakia we talked a little bit
earlier right always has that potential
to be in the upper echelon of the talent
for Dragon Ball fighters underperforms a
little bit at these tour events but I
mean a win over a wall would be a huge
statement and we're gonna see Gohan Vigo
Haan action here that's treat for us
don't go on players so let's go all day
every day been rocking that character
since the beginning it's funny because I
really feel like a lot of those old
Gohan players have just played them
since the beginning and I found them
like so much fun that nobody drops them
right cloud keep some na ki o as kept
them you kept them I've kept them like
Gohan is just one of those kids you
gotta keep wah wah it also helps that
he's just still good
oh you know he's caught a little bit of
some nerves right but then we've all
adapted we got the new leg loops that
you know came after that we we you know
and like the I truly believe that
balance is really important for games
obviously and I think that the designers
had made the right choices when they
toned them down from the very first yeah
for sure a hard knockdown on the edge
fist give it give it back no saying
giving back but yeah I think he's been
one of the best handled characters in
terms of balance for sure because he's
still very very strong right a lot of
players considering top 5 maybe even
better than that so I think the fact
that he's still that state is an
incredible testament to the balance so
far of course there are some characters
got hit a little bit harder right like
we don't get to see 16 anymore
I want I want some 16 love man remember
I feel like that was it you
kill sage is actually somebody who has
put a lot of these characters into our
minds because I feel like that is who I
constantly saw being like the Android 16
person back when Android 16 was really
strong and everyone was using them
however speaking of character
specialists here we do have the base
Goku oh yes right here wah wah
so that is something that I think Nike L
is going to have to really watch out for
not just when it's on offense but also
the assists yes absolutely and this is
really impactful and Lal knows how to
use it like an expert of course it hits
both sides as well so just because you
sell over a lot of time players will
feel safe in situations like that right
with his so over an assist
maybe a little super - back in but a
force base Goku shuts it down on both
sides so you got to be very careful when
combated up against wall want any base
go P player
everybody's handling business here you
guys didn't get to see it but not yell
like a true professional make sure to
disconnect all Bluetooth devices before
getting into the match really eSports
here
all right I think it's just because of
how tall nikhil is he looks so much
bigger right now then well beyond wallah
did you see the fist bump
oh is it it looked like Nagios hands
like ten times the size of wah wah what
was a growing boy man a young player
[Music]
okay I think I have to change the song I
believe so it all right back to the care
just like we're running get back into
the match afterwards
I forgot how old wah-wah actually is but
I know who is it in his teens even if
it's later on like 1819 I believe I
could be making that don't take us to
land of the Kai's I love land of the car
there's there's so much possibility in
this matchup
I think her dramatic finished with Kim
GU and Goku being on opposite teams I
see right yeah you're mine finishes are
one of the best parts of the game but we
just don't get to see them that off yeah
it's like some really like try art stuff
like if you can't really pull it off
right yeah it'd be exciting though I
relish the day indeed but we are going
into it everyone top 32 let's go
winners side we got Wawa presenting
france up against not kill representing
US of A and France give it up for
Porsche Wawa has really burst it onto
the Dragon Ball Fighters Seon has been
one of the most inspiring incredible
players that we've had so we'll see if
not the other make a statement here
media raw Tigers evoke I'm not sure if
that's what he was looking for he has
turned heel I believe the simple - off
that's it
oh and wala find the opening here
one thing we saw earlier when Wall was
playing with Boston consistency with via
sips and extending on the Dragomir
opponent into the corner and the
backbone - yeah Wawa only testing upon
his opponents early with the basketball
while we saw it not yo walk forward a
little bit there by recognizing
subornation in time Venus's does get the
guard cancel out without too much of a
punishing step in the air there Judah
kept with the jump medium off block but
in fact with the opening here you get
these leg loops in the corner I love it
because while not just preys on your
human habits right it doesn't actually
get high enough to do like any falling
mix-up or anything like that
please shows you the animation did not
want to deal with any that catches it
with a delayed garden or vanish in the
air there from sparking yeah love it all
the way someone a DB get off me he's a
TAS mark of his one all blue life they
managed to get the kill it's not gonna
matter here and he will as long as he
gets to smash knock down the end oh yeah
it's dragon ruff smash level one
powered up all the way through the level
for even good stuff Trump and them down
to the ground they're picking them up
already down to character here both
players on sparking I feel like ball
goes into the lab and just practices
fast balls read the key blasts perfectly
not now now applying the pressure on the
corner here we're all out with that base
go food is blocking it out oh come on Oh
super - Jokke oh is that one right back
into it
I'm gonna keep it safe there okay yeah
Big Easy go force is hitting the dark
answer so you get some multiple punished
great defense here from Massey Oh
okay good reflect there all right going
in trying to Oh get the jump medium does
not confirm up a bit yeah tried to bash
up in with the five-mile afterwards and
rather than going to the five at all
right great defense here from Wawa Lima
tried for like altering the timing on
the double overhead finally gets the
head
yeah you just like gave up there for a
second
we talked about all right and I feel
like the treat as a punish the same when
it comes to his own confidence level so
he is going through the optimal vehicles
[Music]
everybody go to assist but it's not
gonna be an uphill great kept therefore
wala yá can lose those no jump and
follow-up and veggie to go to assist and
Super Saiyan Goku been locked out for so
long from life's and soft license oh my
goodness the patients right now from
this man how long can wallow hold on in
the corner
and reflective it is right back to
blocking trimming a message with this
heavy legs oh my gosh how long will we
go for taking the dragonball this is a
young man I told you finally get the
empty long yeah right off that light
incredible block metal damage has to
have been done even despite getting the
kill a knock your side will come off
that top that's the box below oh right
back into it with the two three six the
corners will go forward this is a change
of pace for sure right now but we have
Bullock baby out yeah this is the Bears
the main chicken this is the one you put
us up on the map with
try chasing diarrhea like the way not
yell complaint and so far huh Oh almost
up across up there I just keep it nice
and basic at this point right 6m into
the goal harnesses can extend with the
power pole get them all the way to the
corner here
dragon rush and not gonna be able to
take the first game over Wawa what a
change of momentum there - it looked
things were looking very grim almost yes
yeah absolutely
and he managed to just come back from
that I mean it really felt like Wawa was
just sending a message with the blocking
at that point right it was just like you
know anything you throw at me I'm gonna
end up blocking and it was looking like
a lot of mental damage is gonna be
incurred but no knock yell bouncing back
the thing that was crazy to me is even
every dragon rush was tagged yeah any
option he went for he blocked and Zelos
he take dragon rushes he blocked
multiple overheads I mean the kids
defense is unreal however not yell kid
fine enough openings to take the first
game and as I mentioned he's
underperform at these Dragon Ball Tour
events but a big win over Wawa would be
an incredible statement to make right
now and it's something that Nakia has
been working on relentlessly ride
tirelessly his mental composure his
mental strength showed in that last game
it almost looks like father and son
right now besides this matter if you've
never met doc Yan real-life I beg he's
taller than you yeah like Goku and Gohan
right now yeah
voila though doesn't look too shaken
either no Walla Walla really is
strategic at keeping his composure I
feel yeah
so let's go into it - here we go
it's a super - there was therefore not
yawns again
we'll follow it all the way through
further smash the stops when we go final
right there for the munching himself of
all what does not want to take you to
more blocks tricks opening their big
super - gone going to snap out here
bringing a baked tofu not knows marigold
pizza moth
this is a hole on snap that's half right
now it's great for oculus well because
he wasted all that smart time wall while
use the sparking and it's not even gonna
save a character oh boy we drop it
this is his spell all wrong his base
book will live but another castle to the
to rage he's been looking for them we
got the brush here this is gonna be a
deaf part off the floor to sound like
that a level of a nice and Navi a
commanding lead base go through barriers
any life left luck you know doesn't have
a stretch of day and why
Bardock like that that's gonna hurt I
don't know I don't know if I drew the
switch right now you know I feel like
this adult go on is just fine yeah
absolutely
Bardock not doing a thing thing tomorrow
ok heavy legs going in the GT Goku you
are locked down there sir we were just
asked a girl would go hon Louis is
needed Auto combo city and a side switch
no yes bring it down alright heavy legs
out just to buy some time there
stuff all out to our lockdown goes for
the low and that kid blues is the brain
equalizer I've no matter how good your
blocks are it's real tough to give it
the Calathes
I mean quite a sociable counter folk
this might be the momentum switch that
Wallabies
all right go to the pirate camp and then
are we gonna see a level three from GT
we are way too much damage on the table
as possible I am because he's side
switch with base boat who he's gonna
side some deafness level 3 again it
happened in the corner smart stuff for
all
the cross mark
[Applause]
Barack's again alright you are locked
down here while the see fence again
nobody helps would have block that I
feel oh but he finally gets opened up
here so late the by then just long
enough to catch Wawa moving Springpad
and get the full health get boo in
[Music]
five elders of the dragon rush Nakia
yeah this is total change of pace here
now yell very dominant in this game as
compared to the last was a little bit
more even sided I feel throughout most
of it this is very very strong here when
I yell and clash with the super dashes
well he's gonna be big chillin here he's
got the goal harnesses yeah I like that
calling it while he jumps over and
running get a little bit damage in where
he can
the other side Nakia takes it little
drop a character in the second game
I mean Wawa was definitely the favorite
coming into the tournament so knock yeah
fooling them some after sitting in the
losers advancing on the top 16 winners
side hey we talked about a ride knock
you a bit of an underperformer when it
comes to these Dragon Ball Tour events
of a man a win over Wawa the favorite in
the tournament this is how it should be
playing I agree absolutely he just went
in there at first like I said I don't
really agree with Wawa switching you're
playing adult Gohan debarred off it was
Bardock was gone too fast don't go on it
just seems like a stronger character for
Wawa and his play style especially with
his team yeah you could tell just the
difference in pacing that that made it
knock yells game that second game NBA
sake ale taking it to over Wawa sending
a statement letting everyone know he
should be considered one of the
favorites to take the entire tournament
here at first attack and that was just
our first batch of top third you see
Robin over Oh
[Music]
here we got something good good ace
dragon ball indeed we got super noon
coming back up
mr. anger himself going up against
fidelity the man we saw just the fear a
raid to make top 32 winterside that was
insane I was watching that from the
backside of the the screen here and Wow
because he plays Broly yes right yeah oh
my gosh there was like one moment where
he just straight up walked up and
grabbed with Brawley in it when probably
just straight up comes up and snatches
you man he just snatched her wig yeah
exactly was Brawley out here snatching
up wig dude and the thing is too is that
he puts his opponent in situations where
there would be able to like up tech and
then they can back - or GG up normally
but he calls the freezer assist in those
situations what brings you straight to
the ground and that's when he'll sneak
in a Broly command grab so you got to be
very wary when fidelity has that
presence is available I'm sure there was
a I think anyway rare it used to be a
marble player right yeah there's
probably only half respect between the
two of them said yeah this man's hat
right yeah we say Jenna was talking
about that beginning of course Ray Ray
ran finalists at Evo 4 mana vs. Capcom 3
and then of course very good at infinite
as well so both of them sharing similar
history but only able to get the better
of them this time but super noon of
course also sharing a Marvel background
close the top a needed evil a couple of
times with Marvel 3 we leave tonight so
yeah definitely came into his own
towards the end of that game and really
wrote that momentum from alpha 3 someone
will in announced the Dragon Ball
fighters and it's just improved his
version style gameplay over the course
of the three games and on the other hand
fidelity who was already proven he can
hang with the top dogs defeated Ray Ray
let's see if we can take down another of
the us's Titans yeah super nuna is
definitely not shy of being one of the
USS I you know we've seen him perform
really well it seemed like he was having
a little bit of a character crisis for a
second
after yeah what did the nurse to self
self nurse we saw we saw a little bit of
a shift super Newton definitely was
dominating with the
CEL kid buu going on for a while and you
know it's great to see him finally find
his footing and what we probably could
say is one of the strongest three
characters you can play together right
now oh yeah for sure he's itching for
any like more of a top-tier team right
we got kid food got bar knocking we got
GT Goku three incredibly strong choices
an incredibly strong team and we're
gonna see he's gonna be able to ride out
the victory
see what happens here especially because
Rolly can't be clumsy pretty easily here
by especially characters you know I love
Superman already shutting down that
super - option right get in there points
out snapping back down pretty kitty
I'm saying that the that's probably the
biggest problem on Superman 15 for
fidelity near Balazs he's the plaintiff
you for so long
exactly that's Lena's best character the
character that he won combo breaker
random tournament win can't forget about
that we have a switch side not trying to
deal with that sparks early here maybe
up to six seven use the air - counsel
happy words to try to preserve some of
the meter but instead was running back
with Bart oh yeah the partner of the
test never gets old forever good going
level three up to the second character
now wonderful see it early sparking or
if you will just hold this okay
[Music]
that's nap I do not know if this will
pay off for him at all free zone kidding
is you get it served right now I'm a
smartass level three already definitely
get his stuff pushed it for sure we got
some level three knock down here
fidelity you gotta think about sparking
an hour old try to bid out again there
we go wait till he blocks the kid buu
assist great well done
nice discipline I agree with that
especially oh there we go to find his
footing there all the reasons that we
didn't get the convoy towards the 5m and
the raw tag it's super-new now that
students are you know
rock that could just be the better
option it's one of the best defenders of
the game for sure and we got the dragon
rush he showed him the kid buu assist
right now I'm thinking about blocking
down think about reflecting only to make
some guys super nerd always always
trying to go in strong a beginning of
the game
oh here we go take a questionnaire back
- instability right there we're bringing
it frees up that you watch TT play the
last game freezes very strong for
fidelity correct yeah absolutely
does we know what he's doing with it all
point on it says he seems like a long
time player of the character really
comfortable in these new situations
where you don't expect freed the players
to know what to do yeah I mean he is
going up against GT Goku at the end of
the day just the broglie's super dude
looking pretty solid this first game
just have to take quick work of the
crawley should get out of this old man's
breath and D that's two characters for
one right here just there's a level
three elbow that's gonna kill kit boom
do a lot of damage to GG go through
yeah if you can get that snap outs get
that blue help this could still be a
potential win for fidelity here we go
he just has to really track it that snap
this is the biggest opening he's really
could have asked for here so you can
make it happen so yeah he's really about
that keep last life when he has bullion
points so you got to watch out for the
pre-emptive super - just trying to call
out the starter for the key glasses
can't cancel it this could be its
characters weight report right now being
in the corner all the blocks done
respects it and the dragon rush was
there to follow up yeah that jump ass
good work here in the first game from
super noon man Tasha cow was hair I can
see it even back there me and my eyes
were just drawn to it he's a he's off
the screen now he's a gem called it the
Joe Dirt haircut and I was like you're
not wrong oh thank you thank you and I
was like I do miss the ponytail though
oh I told him I missed the ponytail it
was great because it was like a little
top ponytail I really yeah I was a big
fan of ponytails here yep his hair is
evolved and see what the first thing he
said to me though was I drop 18 told me
he dropped her again he had to break my
heart like that I was gonna say he
remembers from combo breaker where you
like
but he's headed for Frieza which I
caught up you know I respected you you
love your Frieza yeah bring out the food
with cheetah okay okay I like it I want
to see but that - this is gonna be
damaged reckless vanish out of the
corner right there a lot of top players
I'm gonna be looking for stuff like that
super new scouting it perfectly there's
gonna be a lot of pressure take on yeah
this parking probably it's good choice
to make here just to get out of the
sticky situation great reflect there
from the super news
just super dad price laid-back in there
Oh looking for it to be in the air there
but not quite right
finals pudding Barbara don't opening
that all those
well what is the word on the priestesses
flip some you get to the other side
Coughlin off speaking of vanishing back
into the corner I'm very impressed with
the conversion obviously all voiding the
addresses what is about that is the
delay course of the floor as usually
beats a media reflect but you come over
here
super new trying to find his opening
again great defense though for fidelity
but how long can be hold on
yeah parameter for those super news kid
food the raw tag his tourniquet but he
decided to do that rock tag now he's
blue Geno's back in Bardock you have a
sister company you just go put miss
don't even go to high or low track caps
in the air I try to look for that as
well all right freaks out though his
character but man that came blasting all
the classic other classes continue to
cycle through all these characters but
he can't find a big hit and that's what
he's looking for right like he was
looking for that opening there
oh the choo-choo train came to town and
it did not hit it went off the tracks
uncontrollable beat that chest super-new
takes the first character
[Music]
lose a bad game not no sparking for the
dog that's not severe toward linear but
gets rid of one tries to use the age
ground but now it's stopped out this is
not looking good here for fidelity super
news looking even cleaner than the last
game here still Nets barking octet yeah
Ben bar knocks the only one that's
suffered significant damage so far
exactly what super noon whining them to
and he's gonna seal it too old and move
on and winner's bracket big uh stupid oh
you know that was win aside for this
dude being losers on the qualifier
further in the tournament super noon
though channeling the anger he was like
yeah exactly being the chest it's
definitely a shirt of a kid blue player
squeezed about well he had to take care
for a little bit he was reckon I am
I mean most people might think is like
Goku rose' but I I saw the Kid Buu and
solve it solve a in her kid boot exactly
that's why you talking about behind it
blue and I'm like for what what he needs
to go back to the pink that's his
character that's his character was so we
were just looking at
I mean what is it the bargain yes yes I
would have to be for kid buu man and he
really I can only see him getting away
with because he wants the kid who a blue
color a lot so he's gonna have to become
a fifty I mean that's what I'm saying
yeah I mean I forgot that I was watching
once I remember they had to go cuter
shirt on and then they like all it was
Wednesday night five lazy man man came
to with the Gogeta shirt and then didn't
play Gogeta
shameful I think I was hoping I think he
ended up playing seventeen but there was
a guy at co taki that was wearing the
monster Island yeah sure man you better
be wearing you better be wearing that
and plan the MVP bro he really was he
got the biggest push and Dragon Ball
super he was the MVP of that show close
definitely so we're gonna get another
top 16 qualifiers match here and this is
that another banger we got echo fox to
kill sage on the right going up against
our MC from the United Kingdom on the
left the strong EU players but it D kill
sage very strong us player yeah one of
the strongest us play is for sure
champion of thunderstruck got himself a
nice amount of points at that sank ihe
event big ups of the kills Hagemann I
remember at that tournament he was like
man you know I've come I've come to
grips with the fact that I'm never gonna
win a major and I see what you did
reverse curse it yourself you're not
slick ya get those you kill freak did
some chat
yeah man to kill see cuz this thing
streamer as well always checked into his
stream is a lab moat monster he's always
been training very informative but if
you are trying to learn something you
will learn something in his stream you
might even make some friends yeah he's
got a very chill chat very chill dude
right slit-like reflects upon him oh we
got this again I'm just gonna zip it
[Music]
y'all with the eyes open ah bro shut up
the grandma Goku is just her birthday
the other day karachi boys 10 and we do
have the japanese voices on so it is her
that's what I'm talking about you kill
sage already going in there we saw the
model public already but the first bit
here is going to go to our theme had
already started off well using the
perfect attack so he can banish him back
into the corner will delay it arise from
the kill stage so now the situation
doesn't punish the would reflect off old
traits there but the hit is going to go
to our MV this could be easily
opportunity yeah huge would of
opportunity presented the sage at this
point so now our MV guys know he's
thinking about it wrong tag exactly he
wants to get that blue light back on
sell old find the opening it's a low
there the far not going to tag back in
team go on get that blue help out of
there yeah this is the character that he
should have had a kill on already so you
know we just longing will he beat the
man he's with a 5 out it was a light
versus light situation there all those
get off me my man our MC well done
shining star character for the same page
here though Brawley looking perfect jump
in the air there we've got the heat last
managed safely slipper solid for all we
talked about his eye strain control in
general that's really what he makes the
most of use of the room always just
trying to put out the key blasts and
then really recognizing when he's close
enough to take advantage of those long
normals you see right there perfect
spacing I'm at five oh yeah
six minutes
sliding knocked out their success with a
spark alarms you're gonna be the first
one to spin a sparking and he actually
catch the kill safe ride manage him
again
right showers back in all right sparking
up the kill fades there reflux cell but
still gets the hit
do it look for rmz here notice available
now the barn off is there m6m locked it
wants a double overhead as well great
thing system that kills if you need it
when you play a big body like this
cancel for you our MC that extension off
of that so much damage it's gonna be it
don't meet her necessary okay just like
that the tables almost evened up here
yeah so got a full help DT Goku but no
saves in a much better position that he
works one thing I think that kills H
does really well here is not only just
his movement in the game but also his
use of staggering he blasts especially
from a distance the jump leading out so
from I think I was coming here for
partner yeah the to his moving it from
left to right now I got level three take
about the corner
good damage here from the power of bow
see if our MC goes to the cross if this
things occur for the safe jump Oh try to
pay something out
while the dragon flash this meets them
in the middle and all of Z takes down
the gold food that dragons last fist
I felt it into me but it hurts it lets
me in the heart Wow no no this not
another kill Saints the one that comes
out on top get him out of here force him
to fight with one character arms he
trying to wiggle on income
go in there and casa Oh try to get with
a graph but
man RFP saw it come jumped out
lay egg again yep that's a pudding
that's come in that five minutes so good
tries to run it right on with a command
grab but again arms he jump it out
glance yeah make sure that he has to
block cuz he just goes reflect key
blasts Oh actually hit the super - while
he trying to smoosh it up this time I go
with the age with arms he is ready with
that on the reflect
this is a scary situation right now for
the kill stage the peanut but I mean a
comeback he'll be Haney doesn't stick
bars open
oh and he's been really relying on that
stagger pressure riot we see him slow up
the to em again Kanzi on the feet now we
got one b1 can t come back
I mean arms he's not be careful if he
applies it he blocks trees because the
kill Sage has reversal level 3 meter Oh
up there we're gonna see a level 3 here
for sure and smash it back there we go
this is the start of it all right here
you got one more confidence survive my
friend commander oh goodness I've
brought it up for the kill tapes but
that Carl gave arms eena meena to do it
and he's not afraid 102 UK spies the
kill sage was so close yeah definitely
are absolutely come back there
baccala reversal level 3 man testicle
hey it on to kill stage last game losing
team Gohan too early so I would like to
see him maybe make a little bit more
work and it will probably be better for
him especially we can get Dodd in the
way
you caught the back cast on Xena one
with the momentum early on in the game
once again
and smash knocked down with a rolling
attack oh that hesitated for just a
second caught the kill sage press upon
those hesitation like really make or
break you in this game oh yeah
[Music]
so look for this age here yep evening's
a couple off that
oh yeah I like that just walk up to of
arms you will miss Fitness parking early
again he wants to preserve that whole
team for as long as possible you need to
go go back now that was so smart from
our MC right there because usually when
you see mash is there going to be in the
corner right you always reflexive you
get the full couple punished but he held
it faded it out and punish the kills
they for being smart that kills through
the 6m and trying to air that afterwards
obviously the most able to follow to
that is old fashioned to the age what's
not gonna happen
opens over the wrist coming on the Hans
well he's got plenty of borrows that
that's a dead Rolly
[Applause]
the kilts it's definitely one of the
favorite to make it a tough game but
right now our NZ's showing that you
picked wrong oh yes you're very you
don't see for Dragonball fighters one of
the finest UK representatives if they
got all this up yeah Mike that opening
with the low there here we go going into
level 3 super faint go through
[Music]
that most marketing on either side as
well as the kills they're gonna follow
this up with yes his dad shall dragging
the rush I felt it deep in my bones
tequila says won't bill to the floor
though so he's gonna have to do one for
level three I'm not gonna kill
with a little bit of help up after this
[Music]
run up jab burn up bid yeah
don't pick something stare at their arms
even you holding up
[Music]
trying to - no less and less that are
now that's something that when I trained
with the co-state he was trying to teach
me to make sure you do is always cover
yourself when you're super - and zeros
like use that I feel like that sucks the
gameplay that we'll see when he tries to
going on offense he will use that
offensive advantage to just try and keep
it C cr-z attempting to give him a
little taste of his own medicine but the
kill save ready for the dragon rush
after the local 3-ball but arms came out
ready for the dragon rush after the air
block the trade but someone's gonna with
this trait here that's the thing when
you trade with so you usually kind of
like bounce back a little bit and go
who's gonna die CW looms when it comes
to the lights so you can't just swing
with always guys through the mediums we
got hit there with that diet he'll be so
rich that's gonna kill all right I'll
chase him down from the sky at the age
rmz have you tried for a perfect attack
I'm not sure either way the kill stage
takes down his cell sad we're not going
to get the dramatic
finished yeah is a shame just keep
swinging on the back of the neck again
filling a bunch of meter in your ball
boobs not even gonna need it the casein
you kill stage coming back from that to
my goodness very close game 1 and game
tuned here which we are MZ and the kill
sage who the best Dragonball fires
players on the planet
yes Magda see the difference in their
philosophies right there are MZ opening
up with 5 min but either way he's the
one that gets dragon run the kill snakes
feeling the emotion of a team go hot in
this you know once the 16th player
Cena's head gets pressed it feels the
hurt yeah feels like this is what the
death it's my character kind of channel
the anger totally different play right
near the beginning a much more dominant
team go on
[Music]
Aarthi boolean this time
oh that's GT koku Beeman he's gonna do a
little bit of a hit there
yeah the arms he's gonna jump up and
convert for a full combo great up there
I'll try to get in with that two S's put
my blog
the time here on a lot of this is really
good for the kill stage but that is
gonna be a 2h on those legs they're
doing a great job challenging the fall
of that gets late
oh we're trying meet him in the middle
with that jump in l wasn't ready for the
super - though now both this is
available that's why he reflects before
it you're really getting close and that
to Ames on the super - yeah kills a
saint don't super diction in on me today
gonna have to disguise a little bit
better
okay the key blaster do it I see you I
see you
and we're jump each with into the keep
last night that set up Thomas Boleyn bus
is playing it nice and safe
Oh back off their opening this would be
a dead poor dog
yeah counterhit arms he was looking to
get a quick reversal bite in there but a
kill stage staggered the street at just
enough
[Music]
all right covering with both physicist
again on that super - never trying to go
in recklessly to the - OS mor Z right
there
[Music]
going for the look for another kid here
this example our covers you the pieces
afterwards again the spacing here so
important to especially when you're
playing [ __ ] Goku since his autopilot set
so far you know you'll sake finds the
hit there stands all across the screen
nice the Killa saves the optimal token
combos here he is dead are you gonna
deliver will see the kill sage gives us
the lure finish we're all hoping for to
deliver he blasted he tries to approach
hey job yet oh my goodness is jumping
over the kamehameha a punishing would
keep less of his own kill sage really
setting up a saint shop near
the bonuses grant them again follow up
and clean this time just goes level one
level one two two one that kill sandwich
its cannon enough for me I'll take it
don't take it away huh all right
whatever good enough for now as the kill
stage able to move on in the top 16
winners bracket bouncing back from that
first loss the arms he gave him in the
set rate stuffed arms either again that
was winners side so he's gonna be still
alive and losers bracket trying to
qualify for that top they trying get
these points at the Tenkaichi event to
qualify for the finals yeah that's what
everyone's out here they're hungry and
they want fed those points indeed and if
you're hungry go get a quick snack
Kazumi right back on Dragonball fighters
quick break and then more top 32 don't
go anywhere
it's two men winners finals losers
finals grand finals final game on all of
these for Dragonball
early break Larry can max no spark no
you even have me a sister anything like
that but he's gonna go back gg-go food
here this all the blog's on the agent
below and reflects out of there and now
sonic Fox at all suit there you go sign
o'clock to jump in especially with it I
can we see Joey Jean just stay down with
Brian mixing that up a lot stays in the
front no it's this available this is
where sonic usually finds his offense
well the assistant yeah he couldn't
confirm that was a little too much walks
come from walking green cheese button
you get a quick dash and I need to stop
it looks like you know what you could
hit me I'm
sonic running him down he's got the
hippo assist here the mix-up well I
think he waited for guard cancel or to
see if you try to reflect or something
did you go to assist he's gonna have the
stagger yeah but you knew it I play in a
button and that's a beautiful cross up
with the M lariat
three this is a solid mix of app that
will see if this force without
potentially the final spark in the
episodic
the damage goes for the cross let's get
them out of the corn for now wow it just
instantly hits right
yeah that's bark out ll is something we
see a lot from Sonic big drop Oh
standing like right next to go see that
like what a plaque this is huge not oh
man that's part cause the table right
but sonic drop that compliment would've
been all this parking damage that is
huge in this game you really need to
maximize those moments why at the bluebe
tap as far as that man oh man lots of
drops from Sonic so what are you doing
now crash level 1 for the kill yep blue
beat combo drop combo sonic Fox is
sparking off the table
the huge momentum swing the one thing he
does have is lots and lots of meter you
can make something happen
you've got to keep finding those hips
though we see it blow EGC we've been
talking about it all day
that's gonna be the hard part finding
that hip getting that damage yeah go
Ichi marks out okay so level one
sparking spent makes up roll to all on
the other side air dash makes up
connects and go each is gonna hit the
loop build three bars and some change
here this is mad looking gives the sign
a contract
six bardos part
Chunkin has damaged his life he won't
get back he doesn't have sparking
available go eat you looking in complete
control they'll try to close out Eve oh
wow the challenge Sonic Fox was ready
for it this is huge he's gonna be able
to get kick crew out of here unless he
wants to run the offense by level one
level three okay
power it up more to this gonna take off
that chunk yeah this is a big chunk of
damage gooey she doesn't ask for yeah
that makes up where to Sonic oh maybe
powerful in front
you gotta have something tricky to get
gooey cheese almost anchors again the
assist goes for the triple stagger
there's the reflect Luigi perfect
defense knowing there's a gap
it'd be back in Sonic he's not gonna
have an assist for a while either he's
gonna fight this real honest 2h on the
super - to assist or cancel without the
father got him out of danger
lemare dashing back roars coming on halt
with power pole trying to snipe and then
attack using a full movement steel sonic
Fox feeling it he's gonna build four
bars which is enough to sell and I set
up the level three yeah he just goes for
the power table one now not even going
for the spirit ball
one more mix up here's enough to close
out this character - that's what's scary
the boo assist wow he broke the track in
a rush we went through the assistant
everything that was crazy the assistant
knocking down with Bartok there so that
sonic couldn't - out stagger pressure
jumps away catches the auto up oh this
is huge the game is all tied up sonic
folks is down so much no Sparky new
character the piece five bars between
them right now the Power Poll remedy
blasts sonic on the hunt he doesn't have
a neutral assist like we talked about in
the front that's the fake-out
he's got a level three for the end of
this Bombo
chains no level three bagging pressure a
little bit
oh man the blocks from Sonic jumps back
Auto combo miss y'all pack em finds its
mark that's gonna be big damage he has
five bars yeah that's the end of kid
Goku here and that's the thing about
gooey cheese been jumping and uh packing
a lot and really using that to throw off
my bosses timing it catch stuff like
that Auto combi whippin last character
between go Ichi and Evo championship and
he take out Sonic boxes Kid Buu
[Music]
sonic pots gonna need something things
feel aware break the dragon - runs into
the keel a sonic Fox is moving in he's
got to get in and make something happen
to jump over Kokua says he falls on it
ticks set up nothing from sonic defense
is solid chasing him down you see the up
back from coochie that's where sonic
wants to get over the air throw mix-up
almost had a conversion he air dashboard
almost got caught the block it's pole
sides I'm blocking both sides now age
missiles iqbal this is huge
sonic Fox holy some challenge GUI G was
ready for it he brings them up this is
it
drop them keep it simple there it is go
Ichi your Dragonball fighters 2019 Evo
champion after overcoming hand injury
he's in tears
up there defeating sonic Fox to claim
victory here on the winners side
nonetheless and know the real tears
right there this has been eluding him
for so long last year he reset the
bracket sonic Fox plush it out to eg
somehow just won his very first
championship for this game after being
so dominant for so long he is your Evo
Dragonball Fighters shape
you
welcome
you slash Dragonball Fighters of course
I hope you enjoyed that blast from the
past we're go Ichi won evo 2019 is this
like first of a motion like it always
gets me on the verge of tears definitely
made me cry at Evo but it always gets me
on the verge of tears memorize it and of
course Sonic such a the best opponent
possible right just give them a hug with
a big ol smile yeah I love that moment
it's a true story of two rivals that
also just get along so well so super Big
Ups to both of them they are not here
this weekend but they will both be at
the finals and France I am sure of
course go eat you already qualified
sonic has a billion points so he's big
chillin but of course we are gonna move
on a top 32 winners side here trying to
see who gets those points who joins
Sonic & Go eg at the finals heavily next
up we got oh i don't disappear but I
believe it's apology man vs. big buck
Jackson yeah big butt Jackson man we
have seen a lot out of him today and
Puerto Rico is super excited about him
making at this mark they were jumping
for joy giving a big hugs after his win
getting into top 32 here we are sure to
see some fun from him he plays Vegeta
let's go Jackson let's see let's see if
he can turn this around
now apology man looking very strong
still playing that snap Metta oh yeah I
feel like when you play piccolo each
piccolo is different but the one thing
that they all have in common is they do
the snap that up yeah yeah I know why
wouldn't you right when it comes to
piccolo you have so many ways to doing
the setup shop with the hell's own
grenade of course to make their incoming
a living hell but all just on top of
that I think the snap meta is still very
strong just because it forces the
opponent to fight with one character we
talked about how good rata is the
defensive mechanic in the game earlier
and that completely locks you out of
that for eight seconds a lot see I'm
calling you assist walks you out of
guard cancel all those defensive options
are taken away and pretty much the only
resource you have spent on defense is a
spark yeah
gonna say I think it is definitely one
of the easiest ways here to get an early
sparking from your opponent absolutely
hands down and there's that go Gina Oh
Gogeta don't go hard and Goku super
savage in the back the team is just
insane with swagger yeah oh and you put
the go cheetah theme on all right this
apology right with a man that named
Bigfoot jack says well Paul go ball you
gotta have that big booty team you know
what I'm saying
Vick with two Z's yeah the whole family
we got three C's for that shows what
kind of invited because he fused just
kind of just kind of there you out you
right yeah all right so apology man
representing the US of A of course PR
big but Jackson representing PR photo
Rico
I love that he already doesn't go back -
into the jump to avoid the beam assist
call it the starch already showing some
great knowledge however abolishing that
able to put below anyways gonna start
here with him being in the corner again
below the table would get big but
Jackson not sure when it took his turn
[Music]
because big damage level one from teen
Gohan and ago people there so he did get
to H exactly all the unblockable now get
the love walk from big Jackson is he
likes to do the shoulder drop go right
into it yeah five into the ultimate back
attack is unblockable it's not actually
a block full but I've never seen anyone
blocking I like to use the fastball
trying to mix it up here it goes right
back it with jump media keeping it safe
here and when you're leveled up like
that - that oughta problem this becomes
really strong for you great timing on
the guard cancel all ball you can that
only eating the beam as a punishment and
then punishes the reflect
let the right see change oh no you just
were blocking hi Esther there man they
said that go harness the meatus Gilley's
rough but teen gohan is there for the
extension yeah survived without the
extension I think but yeah what's he
going on
and well done now Vegeta back into the
fray or no tech boys
several bars on deck as well of course
he's got the little five but I think
he's gonna spit it here doesn't gonna
spend the level three
[Music]
we're all attack back in it go who may
be trying to catch a pursuing apology oh
he just eats it I mean that means that
carrots are my friend
yeah he was gonna block the initial here
it's once apology man winning they were
piccolo he would spark up but no it just
isn't even the health of grenade
I mean apology management point is
character for two years now alright so
he's gonna know how to convert off the
only saw that he's not saying it on
another character yeah matches the buff
as he's lying in wait always got to be
aware of that grab an option
all set it all the way level three with
that in the back sparking yeah feels
real bad big but Jackson game face on
though character select screen we go is
that like the permanent like slightly
raised eyebrow like doing the rock
Johnson always looks like somebody just
told him really bad news even when he
was on his good side
he's winning you're winning an apology
man but he's like you know there was
that tweet that came out that was like
the people that think more are gonna
live like a less amount of time right if
it contributes to an earlier death and
beneath doesn't have anything to worry
about he's gonna live a long healthy
life that's all I got to say big but
Jackson trying to bounce back here
bounce that booty back how could I have
not seen that
man this lie don't play by the game's
own copy all bad I was a sick jump
alcohol the super - of course piccolo
got one of the best ones in the game
doing that hey you can see he was
walking towards the piccolo - he would
got clipped by the in Savannah
[Music]
okay I like this pressure to work here I
got a loved one man there's a lot of
damage on the vocal level 3 but I gotta
imagine it's a pixel you can't actually
here we go level 1 and level with the
Dolan I like this stuff but he couldn't
get the 5h afterwards usually you do
that and then go directly into the loops
none of you love about though yeah deal
with it
it's almost like a game of keep-away
when your opponent has sparking like you
don't let them to be near you exactly
right that's what a lot of players have
just decided to do when their opponents
box is just run away wait for that
timing to go up of course it when it's
level one it's only seven seconds
however I apology man does fine and hit
afterwards
[Music]
[Applause]
what's it gonna be yo Tina in alright
sparking here not trying to deal with
any of this piccolo not set here the car
cancel catch him to recovery in that
movement that leads up in the middle
apology man with the teen gohan making a
work that need a little bit more of an
extension to build to that bar Gogeta
leaving big butch accent down to his
last two characters choose to go for the
smash yeah all of the instead of drop
the button to drop the bow
dropping something like a tie that's all
that matters dropping the phone like
it's hot
Oh fastball okay it consisted out of the
heavy right there yeah BP poison into
that real quick and then the to wait for
apology on the other side yeah it's like
you're trying to beat out that super -
there I like the use of that
Pet Pals underneath so we got
great reflex on them oh yeah counter
here look like a Pollock you know once
you land and start trying to press some
burns again I've been put by the wrong
time so anybody's game at this point
okay from the jump heavy right to the
dragon rush
we got three bars on deck now that
you're being up hold on to it respect it
yeah I don't think it would have killed
this rod you couldn't get to level four
which was been one three and for sure
death dragon rush will do the deed
though big but Jackson take another year
he's putting some ice in apology man's
milk right now oh yeah
get down real nice so the honey a leader
on your side as well in the back there's
little Polish man he was looking for you
to get antsy
not super now in on this man gets caught
in the air there that was super weird
like he jumped forward kind of like
crossed under him and then double jumps
back to the original side I think that's
what caught they but that's how our real
funky set up now the meter that big Bo
Jackson is sitting on right now is it
good place to be if you can find an
opening here on team go Mon Cheri goes
by for the Petula
you got seven bars on beggar's well I
imagine he gets the more healthy
character yeah and I've been warned oh
yeah oh yeah I saw what you did by the
way big butts it yeah definitely should
of course gotta smash it off down here
yappin till the teleport super there it
is
the crowds going wild for wit go Rico
Puerto Rico likes big butts and I cannot
lie
man how is no fighting game player use
the tag sir mix-a-lot you're right so
especially for this game
all about the mid sea dragon rush okay
he's gonna slam him down not enough
force them into a snap game yet locks
him down once again justice the em-dash
media big but Jackson looking for an
escape but can't find
[Music]
sorry that's the price his special fan
situation multiple times right in the
heart man hasn't try to fit it out they
did bake that reflect out yeah never be
inside just with it
dragon roars knockdown you did to the
sky
[Music]
the cheetah is back on deck since game
two looking a lot stronger for apology
man
connects to the rocket King after the
beep mrs. well always old where oh no
only the drop-down yeah my man was just
walking back from the orb
nice and see look walking across I tried
to reflect right there when the arms are
crossed to reflect when they're down at
the command her gotta try something and
that was the command throw nice jump out
at us from apology man yeah he
definitely needs to work that into his
game a little bit more an apology man
has not been opened up by Nathan in this
game has been great in this game right
now
HR attacks the raw tag with his own jump
flight right there but couldn't quite
find the hidden was looking for
we stagger yeah but apologies man just
jumping out of it very good defensive
choices here I like that combo as well
yeah get them out
now big but ether the health front last
time yeah we're gonna get those spark
yes there we go partner that's exactly
what we expected to see the first time
way for picking let me get close and
then spark up afterwards my eyes out of
youtube so converting off the vocalist
is via the sandwich oh here we go
they have reflected a tall man his
reflect animation so cool yeah by the
auto couple right that's the double axe
handle is the auto combo great jump out
of the command huge anybody apology man
can piglet take a little is good in the
area looks like he was going to jab
there but Paul didn't go through with
the raw tag good look for Fonzie gonna
get gonna honk and I won read it to his
name Vance on vanish to keep that
advance Oh
jump down heavy
and I love the way that books - when you
get the coquito sis extension wall
bounce
[Music]
to the level three are we going to get
the level five
I think it should be so awesome you go
personally yeah gutsy attempt right
there the two and let's let it rock
until you get the dragon rush able to
counter it
oh yeah not the time to pull out that
hang on for dear life here but Jackson
is looking in trouble
our biology man able to afford that
super - attempt to wit the beam once
again Pullo Jackson they're gonna be
negative and that's what apology man
took advantage I'm right there he saw
how high the manage was to his goals
with the dragon flap the cheats you
might say apology man - one over big
budgets well he moves on top 16
qualifiers for the winner but Jackson
not out just yet Berto Rico could still
have their hero yeah most definitely
there's still fewer poor organ players
available aren't alive I should say on
the whites available honey badger is in
winter side yeah there's a couple of
losers bracket as well they're still
alive we got big but Jackson was there
fidelity as well still alive and losers
bracket as far as I know but we are
sticking with the winners side here for
top 32 trying to get into that top 16
and next up is going to be shanked from
Spain going to become subatomic fingers
this should be a good one
anybody I'm familiar with subatomic
sabers and guineas from Southern
California goes to WN f every week very
strong player but I don't know if he's
as strong as shanks right shanks looking
like one of the top dogs and Dragon Ball
fighters yeah he's one of the only top
players that still played Android 18
drive that point home yeah
clicking or saying she's proven it till
it can't be said anymore españa the
father no Padre Oh Padre Grande that's
true run they indeed and I was going up
against sub atomic and subatomic we saw
him on stream a little while ago de
españa rocking a rocking the goat takes
the cell and of course the point here is
there well they usually watch that one
point actually
so we'll see both tanks in the back
and then Shane's on the other hand we
got the Android 18 we got the Gohan
Lilly out cutting checks real quick let
you opportunity once again a twitch.tv
slash Dragonball Fighters rolling on the
top 16 again we're going to top 30 to
the top 16 all the way through tonight
and then we're gonna do top 16 and top
eight tomorrow so do not go anywhere we
are going for another three or so hours
so if you're looking for the Dragonball
Fighters action stay locked and loaded
and give this is button checks real
quick so I think is it tuning in
sticking with us
what a team the but check with Android
21 majin buu hit you'll never see that
what is knock y'all doing back there
what in the world that's definitely a
character's animation all know who
low-key dabbing I don't think so that's
really here that was it was curse I'm
glad he told him that yeah he needs to
know
[Applause]
now shanks on player1 only have the
vegeto how did I forget the Vegeta on
point in the cell back another and go
things at the end Padre
shakes versus subatomic sabers here we
go one player starting off the back -
you can see a larceny showing the what
and airline from shakes hit with the
light their deal with this but it's not
going to matter that's part it's not
gonna get you out of the corner here and
it is a level one sparking yeah showed
up the super - it was hit him with the
FC low the spam low from Andhra 18 so
quick going right into that level three
to knock to be able to spark out of this
gonna get some mix off and it wasn't
gonna be those presents
[ __ ] chump hedge that did not MIT
there because that summer summer savers
all look little for half a second gets
snatched away to being smashed once
again I don't know she snatched my heart
[Music]
still very potent character in the hands
of shames defense all day trying to
sleep little bit too quickly
make quick work here in the corner and
going into the level three
another shanks walk here from this carry
her alive take the momentum back for
himself discipline because the families
they lo the beauty still kicked in
though he's gonna need to ride it out
and he does
two bars if necessary which it won't be
is down Android 18 but shame that the
beautiful thing about this team is
though him guards just stripped you ever
get those so you won't have to try and
sneak one of those in here soon
to really use the pulp oh yeah talk to
the hand 5s
looking to probably try and get him in
the corner to put me yeah hi this is a
decent hitbox you can cry on their phone
besides that's pretty good summer topic
with a nice conversion right there
[Music]
that was sick this goes with the regular
tummy you saw he showed him to jump each
at the very last second just to pull
over the animation that like fooled me
for a second we're right there with the
perfect attack vertical change is trying
to recover from this while this buggy so
actually it's it was a super - very well
that's holding the badge to the optimal
stuff level 3 from Goha yeah basketball
game room the gap needed to talk out
this character pull the fake screen so
it's not the sailors love things I buy
some time to get that Seles is back as
well a little bit too early there for
the dragon run of just shanks gonna be
able to build the two bars here he's
gonna need the so extension to kill no
and he's not gonna have it to set up
shop
both ah he's lovely one to clear the
screen and the level very smart it's
gonna be snapped back into Super Saiyan
Goku
at the last second and then again is
catching shanks trying to press the
buttons subatomic 2/3 2/1 shanks is
levelled up bones great tech they're
from shanks as well with the heavy legs
those prices of the dragon rocks gets
that head secures it yeah a lot of times
players like to reflect definitely aged
legs Gohan and it gets cooked by it
again that's a huge damage starter he's
gonna give the smash knockdown as well
thank you buffs that is how you get
erased as soon as you get hit by those
heavy legs your life flash before your
eyes oh yeah so what's all it started
with the medium as well you can be able
to smash back into the corner here yeah
man the level one will do it subatomic
one all over shakes you know run up and
do like a 2m or something yes something
cuz they're you getting the 299 second
round they both started with a back -
fries so I'm sure he was reading another
back - but
[Music]
a little bit longer this game here
it definitely hurt um 18 for sure for
you jump like falling l and now he's
gonna stab him out lost that go tanks oh
man 17 paid off the cameraman and he's
still blocked left baited it out and
punished perfectly yeah trying to fall
with that right you know getting clip
four is gonna get the go takes out here
a sparking right here I think this was
the right choice made not a save 18 this
side
great defensive subatomic savers
wow what a slight doubt but subatomic
you saw eggs put the 17 assists count
down there right he's busy right actor
called Anna says instead saw the topic
Gordon the attempt of shakes OH
folks from in the mouth yeah that's a
lay there yeah those white love would be
covered in blood that bleach
those are the dishwashing gloves to be
fair can i majin buu blue one yeah the
big dishwasher blue it's opened up here
by go tanks there are three bars on deck
about before yeah some atomic once again
using those pika screams he's so good at
conditioning his opponent to try to run
plenty yet he's obnoxiously long block
screams and because of that he gets away
with stuff like the fake scream and some
atomic savers now a three to one on
shanks another favorite here to go deep
in the tournament we're gonna take it to
the corner with the legs
Oh dragon Royce have bad again sliding
knock down into the final kamehameha
and what's it gonna be after it goes
right into the to end there I think
it's with a sword
not going to be enough here to kill but
things are not looking good for shapes
keeps it nice and simple subatomic
savers takes it to over one of the
favorites of the tournament yeah making
a real real run here at this tournament
here I would say this so I would like to
say that it's not it's not the first
time the Chang's have had to make a
loser's run to get to top eight oh yeah
that's really not unfortunately I'd
always liked to seen him on the winners
side if he is gonna be in but he is no
stranger to getting into loser sighs
papi oh yeah hope you know just lend him
your energy Spain yeah Kula celebrating
yeah of course of atomic and Koopa bolt
WN f regulars ride so they had that
camaraderie right there sparring
partners as well but Big Ups to shanks
right shakes has been one of the premier
players for Dragon Ball fighters here in
2019 so you can count them out as
Romanova was saying just because this
isn't losers bracket
doesn't mean you won't see in the top
eight doesn't mean you won't see him in
Graham fibers precisely and we got no
commie coming up here oh that's actually
yes yeah that's actually yeah cuz we saw
wolf put it to the front earlier caught
me catch him call me catch up you know
he's catching
it's top tier team I was gonna say the
weights in the gym because my man has
been in there
he's been grinding kicking his game back
too but he also gave up on 21 21 is no
longer the bay no she's behind him I did
not see that one coming I'll be on hit
you with the mix-up it's 50/50 I was
boost you you didn't you didn't reflect
that I definitely denial and hold him
there if anything I whip the reflec holy
moly
yeah honey badgers is the man that's
been put it on the bandana in time with
a Bardock intro been playing pretty well
I don't know if you saw that or so this
is the man who's been doing that get
poor he goes oh I'm still alive here in
winners aside I was just saying I really
appreciate his name because of the video
you know everybody's like the honey
badger video course the classic that's
definitely evolved into a classic
gamertag as well now alright honey
badger every scene has a honey badger I
am surprised that no mommy gave up on 21
because it seemed like for a minute with
Mardon
being on his team he had found like that
footing to still be able to use 21 and
go through black yeah so he was using 21
go through black and bar talk for a
minute
but now he's just straight-up given into
the
top-2 year dark side or the pink side
because you have Kabu Kabu yeah
definitely he was the last holdouts for
android 21 I always enjoy watching his
team play like that fun this is gonna be
a blow up if he loses he loses to me you
know I'm never gonna let you live it
down okay so see what he does here is he
times the mitai you put it on he gets it
ready
check out the kick [ __ ] looking at
the screen he's like you gotta start bar
dog this is your gimmick whatever man I
love it let's go I honestly would you
brought up though papi switch the teams
I know you're gonna say how there's a
copy and everything to you there's
another very popular tag here very
popular option to open up the opponent's
the latex right there man so voltage
Ichigo Clarissa's and tech the dragon
rush on the other side very good defense
for honey badger man Mystic Falls
[Music]
bring him down pulls wants the oaky war
after weight loss and the tech on the
Dragon restaurant honey badger means no
more since available you can make
something happen now great stuff on both
sides here well man I hit my one dragon
Russell said never again
Oh what's gonna start it here for honey
badger yeah I've got the counter head
both of them in a scramble situation
right there no commie wanted to keep his
turn going behind bags and finally finds
a hit uses it for a level three
knockdown as well
[Music]
let's go up with a Goku demon to the
dragon garage but sparking here Bobby
gonna find that low hit too with yeah he
lifted the jump in the air line with
country cranes on that or the straight
partners to be honest level 1 level 1
level 1 my fuse over 3
better be safe than sorry right here
yeah of course the level one from Goku
GT until it's powered up is definitely
on the lower end of the damage side so
rather than play that risky game I'll
just spit me up the ball and make sure
[Music]
[Applause]
the sky holds up there you know bigger
follow up I've gotta get something
maybe see the porter flashing right now
indicating me in the sparking heart he
opens a mom locked him down called the
go to his his behind them and snaps out
the total war it's scary
21 is even though
[Music]
exactly yeah very tall
oh yeah cause the bag oh yeah here we go
Thank You Dhamma time throw that hands
up in the air oh yeah he's not gonna
play no games this goal is look the
level one after the safe is secure is
follow up very solid here first game so
far from nope.avi oh but it's side swap
here yeah ended up having the block that
jump in the air line so that's a lot of
box time you're not gonna be able to
move honey badger all shagging love I
like I like the two L's the little 2l
jabs for this but not alive I'm gonna
predict like a raw tag knocked over that
don't
and now it's go Phoebe go through again
no finally full help on his go to as
well he call it the kick Lewis is both
free part way so even after that super -
in half the block it gonna try to flip
one with the two my protagonist normal
great challenge from don't call me I got
a honey badger stagger the pressure for
free
old man just try give lost their lives
right there double instant air - it but
nothing
oh yeah punished on the so long guard
cancelosi the Auto probable to take it
to the sky and smash them down level
three show off the most popular level
three in the game a little bit more yeah
we don't get to see the lot right you
know bar docks was trendy for a while
but now it's we're in the age of Super
Saiyan Goku most it and that's it here
just look we go we see the honey badger
pretty much no character select every
time he's lost I have a feeling he might
switch up the order you were saying that
he has started a fart off before maybe
fart off the better choice to be on
point
yeah so we're just taking a breather
here the character select screen trying
to reset the momentum with no economy
before you're jumpy magnets in the next
match valid strategy for sure for the
saltines arena we go as I got the song
selected no copy is up one all year up
against honey badger honey badger one of
the last remaining Puerto Rican players
in a winter side top 32 so I'm still
alive and losers bracket as well
the Puerto Rico contingent is at his
back they're cheering them on and see
them all gathered around the Dragonball
fighters set up
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go into Game two of you know
back that stuff no copy there all and
usually called the GT Goku - up and hit
on what the two M's it's so shocking
[Music]
pressure tries going for another jump in
there
all right vanishing just dashing up on
their time you'd him in the air
afterwards is excellent place with no
coffee so flying the first game of the
second game excuse me
Oh coming afterwards you got to whip
that time around got three bars as well
wow this actually it's getting help
it's done to the first character second
character pleading heavily oh my
goodness
and calming it snap though with that
honey badger walk at this point right at
you got to be careful on that assistance
part soon just like that 70% of the life
of his Goku is gone and the rest of it
the follow damaged a medium cross up but
dead Super Saiyan Goku man already
making quick work combo early every 21
which is so crispy clean yeah she's got
some of the best double sundae combos in
the game so much damage keeps you both
juggle for so long
[Music]
why Muriel's time to give out does not
this awful
nice reflective course both copies one
of those that's never gonna say it's
also till the tolls ran the junk eat so
much hits done on that allowing you to
follow up
the mix don't be here oh not trying to
have any of that today that's working
for a good reason not trying to deal
with this rat boy gets punished into the
sparking no commies can be able to make
some war here up is over 21
yeah very smart little authorities even
if it's not going to do it and you get
the dragon run follow up I think yeah at
level three up hone three hits the spare
takes down and row twenty one great
punished on the raw tag just yet here
although this is not the best position
to be in
oh goes right into direct rush this
could easily beat that Bartok here three
bars already no copies building so much
meat into the Sparky spirit bomb and
what's so good about those last two
spirit boxes that they were both killed
so that means the meter penalty is not
there for this next character you still
get that increased meter built-in Sparky
and he jumps right over into and get
that hit man making the last two that
smart you count gets the three bars
where you need forward to do it solo
from the Vantage I want to spin it block
it in the air for yet additional blocks
none frames you can now press bars on
that and that is probably good Oh chop
it at the last second here and I'll
taught me a great lesson of the chance
cream and honey badger makes it back
from this that is the drop of a lifetime
impulsive
manages pester here McGee blasts talk
about those lights gonna be no commie
takes a 200 vs. honey badger yeah
absolutely
a dragon rush Tech situations if you're
just gonna fall straight to the ground
you really have to respect you t go
through because that's exactly where the
beam is angled at if you're dope you can
do your own feet right and wait and you
don't actually drop into it you can
counter it that way but he wasn't
looking for that unfortunately and no
Tommy is gonna be moving on in the
winter saw earlier you seemed very
confident in his run here especially
with this new team right so he feels
good about it he's confident I think
that's what you need to keep going
forward and going strong here he's
really looking at that top eight spot
yeah great stuff from no Comi again he
is proven then he is gone some of the
best results there are to get him
dragonball fires right top a medieval
2018 he's shown he can be at the top of
the mountain but hasn't have been
performing as well he's kind of taking a
little bit of a break as well get his
mind right get his physical body right
as you could see my man is like a swole
out there and he is in top 16 winterside
as well
so he will be making it there looks like
we got New York Chris G versus [ __ ]
yeah Chris G also getting second at
thunderstruck I believe so he's shown
that in this latest patch of dragon ball
fires he's a horse to be reckoned with
the kill stage tweeted that he believes
Walla and Christie are the favorites for
the entire tournament so yeah that shows
you how much respect you have to put on
Christie's name and he's here playing
Lord Frieza oh yeah
[Applause]
Lord Frieza and then another poor we can
nade them on the other side and [ __ ] I
think Chris is Puerto Rican and suck and
if I'm not mistaken visiting in the
motherland man I camera we're getting
the the matches on the side here and the
little notes for the commentators and I
completely forgot why why is the losers
side definitely something I did not
expect to say before topics so a wild
man Nakia really made a statement played
super well he's been playing excellently
all day yeah he suffered the smack
attack he did care this election are we
going to you
I can't it's just it's such an American
thing but I can't stop but always think
of the food gas station wah wah when we
see yeah shoutouts to when we've gone to
like CEO when it was at the old venue
and the wall was right there mm-hmm so
well I I don't know if it's ever been
done yet but somehow wah wah needs to
get a picture in front of a wah wah I
mean yeah that's definitely happen right
he's sponsored now so I'm sure he's
gonna be going to more and more
tournaments hopefully you can make it to
next you see or to your Taku somebody
make that happen
in case he doesn't know somebody that is
listening to this stream that knows wah
wah it will be at its war montano bien
make sure if he is near a wall or the
vicinity of one then he yep take photo
with one mm-hmm
it has to be done yeah I mean if you're
like me I've been well I've heard that
name I definitely thought it was after
the convenience store until I found out
he was from France and was like all okay
then I guess it's not for the common
storm
then I was even more cat Donald's like
all right well I have no no read on what
his name is I should ask him about that
actually I'm I was little wah wah sad
about but either way he's gonna be
coming up later we got NY Chris G coming
up right now going to begin sake and I
expect this to be done but check this is
a butt check so Chris G is the hand
warmers experts my man is always bun
checking but I give him and only him the
pass because he plays like 50 games so
because of that I'm like alright man you
know you could take your 15 seconds to
warm up a little bit
Milana the other top like the character
says move forward that Chris do the
playing the freeze a bleep freeze that
thunderstruck I second place with it
been having a lot of fun I talked to him
a little bit afterwards he was talking
about how much he enjoys playing Frieza
in the game so that's definitely why
he's on the team he doesn't think the
character is like super like secret top
tier or anything like that but he has a
lot of fun playing
good character and also has some strong
qualities like that assist
I think the assister Frieza is a
redeeming quality yeah it's definitely
good and ever since he got that buff or
like a lot of the rocks and just a breed
that he summons is able to beat super -
that's that's definitely good look -
yeah the zoning was already good and it
just made it better mmhmm yeah I mean
you need so if you're gonna be his owner
and there's Giggy you need stuff that
beat super - right you can't really be
his owner if you don't so he's gonna
start the freezer it looks like but
Chris G throughout this game twice man
he's really experimented right he's
played with a lot different characters
pretty much any game he touches he
usually explores the entire cast so
we've seen him play the likes of teen
gohan we've seen him try out fidel he
watched his stream he's played dang near
every character in the game but right
now he has settled on the freezer the GT
Goku and the Yamcha really really good
at using the Yamcha sis classic form -
he's been laying out for a while
yeah one of the first time a Yantra
training I recall now all blew
everything on both sides still rocking
the evil geniuses indeed big shout outs
to eg I'm a big fan of they thought a
squad and also I got a shout out to eat
you
[Music]
here go again this is a top 16 winners
qualifying match you got Chris G on the
first player side we got dark beyond the
second player side this is one of our
last winners qualifying matches here
after this we're gonna get Bernie kurta
chicano versus kuba and then after that
we're going to the loser side 21 here on
the screen in d3 popular character here
in Puerto Rico seems intro
that's pretty fire oh my man put the
hood on till you guys can't see it at
home but don't you definitely put the
hood on once the game started got the
game face ready
oh well that animation was going yeah
it's right stuffing prints right there
it is backing off once you get the
corner getting respect to this all I got
man
there but that GT go too obsessed is
gonna hit
right new we bring it in and 21 we're
bringing her in yeah babies to go for a
fuzzy set up or anything like that
empty low good block some great defense
here incredible cross oh [ __ ] again and
then you whip punishes with the chop ass
let's go
okay perceptible that goes for the empty
chair again showing that high animation
alright whipping the jump arrow and then
going for the wall well done
and try to lock them down once again
with a key blast something in debris
sneaking in a sparking loop towards the
end of the sparking as well.all is
optimal all HGH flag this man you saw
him yeah
[Music]
we get it so I have no worry about the
return on the business of that will
clear this fitness marketing role and
the yacht assist again gonna be able to
secure the skill for Chris gee that
sucks
okay yeah I got a little a little
worried for a second there Val you would
like that tag out because there's so
much hit Sun but that last sporting
around a bit
one out there and it's gonna be a lot
less of a worry when from the zoning yes
like she's really good about those air
keep eyes when she's on
point there exactly he could just jump
over a hundred red tiles that Christie
had been throwing and then throw one of
his own back but instead Chris doesn't
lose the Frieza took down one of his own
characters before doing so but we got an
even game here
[Music]
we sparking it's on evoke side slide
life advantage good meter advantage
though has three bars to a half a bar
photography
[Music]
snap out again it's gonna make him fight
solo with a bar docket we talked about
the holy resource you can spit on
defense is sparking when you get snapped
that he doesn't have a double overhead
opening him up all right he has an
advantage the verse company having hot
into the low two three maybe dauntless
set up here now which way we gonna go
all go to the empty low and you actually
brought it great defense again burns off
the GT Gokul assist
[Music]
we've seen Christine mismatched like a
bunch of times off of it
here we go find the opening nose drop it
though ya want the auction system not
sure if he does miss panther or you need
to be close to the corner like a timing
issue for sure
[Music]
old swats is the Yamcha I can put the
jump em afterwards out there as well as
kids talking try to get close wow great
up super dad
you will make fit the hint but gets a
hit from a super dad
wolf move them across interview the auto
hopper right there there's the knock
down goes in the spirit
and if does have to bring the Ichigo
crew back in that's a pretty good look
actually even though the options
healthier you get the option is back you
get this incredible care girl point
and they can block the jumping age so
much blocks on that move
pretty strong care for Christie I was
think he's gonna build the barn
quite enough to build a bar really good
low right there now you were saying that
Christie is one of the favored to
potentially win here yeah yeah the
Kilson yeah yeah the kill stage tweeted
that he thinks Christian wall are the
favorites and you know it's crazy as an
Evo it was Chris G that not wah-wah out
from getting top eight oh wow
I completely forgot about that yeah yeah
Chris has been super good at dragon ball
fires he made top eight this year at Evo
and Dragon Ball fighters all you gotta
put some ice on it man Chris can escape
into the winner's bracket is gonna sign
up for the loser
yeah with losing freezer someone early
glass China potentially this time too
you know
Christine's still very strong even
without that
level 1 level 1 level 1
yeah pixel we can let lower damage on
the DT Goku oh and just like that versus
freeze who's gonna live
I wasn't gonna lie I would have cried I
was laughter if he killed himself it be
Charcot this
[Music]
I'm gonna get that freezin out as well
start building super that wall balance
follow up yeah usually those crusty jump
out Chris James is chasing [ __ ] down
relentlessly here
[Music]
almost contract off
that was not the time to call an Android
21 yeah very scrambling here in getting
to Cristo hasn't in the corner and to
assist available to his name John show
coming out really soon
there it is and then the double overhead
again he didn't believe and they try to
go for a reset after work then he worked
for the full auto Pablo that's a whipped
grab at the end a little bit of blue tip
that's why I like the yellow color to
the all gold everything concerned about
the fight anybody doesn't convert
[Music]
it's a fellow tale there
Mambo's across the screen is what I love
so much so high level or the one more is
dead spirit [ __ ] do enough damage
here
nice and slow Regina strike a first
blood once again Android 21 already in
the grave
Spike's them out I got the headshot with
the key blast into the freezer all
sparked up yeah
called his boy sorbet hey Gus put a
meter on it but that is an option once
you're golden Frieza love that anybody's
game he's gonna find a healthier team
[Music]
help your team more meter does get the
vanish as well to avoid crispies off
lockdown on the ground
Wow with the big trophy there we go yeah
to properly extended that time
just get rid of this character knowing
that it's it's really help Sparta
while super - with our utility skies on
those who Asian using these instant air
that backwards
yeah
the thing is GT vocal also has a pretty
good jump right oh wow it's um Lobo and
Puerto Rico is cheering right now for
turkey character Kristi's I'm powered up
little one they even need the power up
but he does gain it after one of his
team members dies
[Music]
my father may be trying to H direct
flash this
what make this
[Music]
oh nice
Chris disguising when exactly he's gonna
do the process of little things is
perfectly yeah yeah yeah I like that I
like the movement here I like the
movement going with the key block and
set us back
who is going to make the first move in
right now though a lot of patience here
for both players
Wow snapping mixer oh oh it just
punishes with a snap l super smart stuff
encouraging here he's in that the dragon
rush not even extends for the smash that
way spirit ball will do it to hold for
eg Christian yes pop 16 winterside so
Big Ups to eg zone again made top eight
at Evo 2019 got second place at
thunderstruck Chris G really found his
tribe of Dragonball fighters ect as well
coming in top eight and now that was a
lot of your top 32 but it's not over
just yet we are gonna take a quick break
here gonna commentator swap going and be
right back with some more action please
stay locked and loaded on twitch.tv
slash dragon ball fighters stick around